aucun des responsables des bains et
chaque semaine ouais tu vas venir nous
présenter le chouchou de la semaine
comme à la bonne époque dorée c'est
alors qu'est ce que c'est cette même
manière si quelqu'un qui n'est pas
créateur de chauffage qui habite à lille
et cousin de pierre d'albi ouais c'est
quelqu'un dont on parlera beaucoup en
quelques années qu'elle veut tout à
l'heure qui a une voix exceptionnelle
c'est très chouette qu'on pourra
comparer avec américain il était certes
heures de l'armée il habite en
angleterre numéro où il couvrira les
corrections de ne rien rater de zinal
habitudes abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus